in an article published in US News and
World Report were shown again how
government can make almost anything
worse in the wake of the opioid
crackdown the CDC had said that
painkillers should be a last resort for
patients the result medical societies
greatly reduced prescriptions insurers
refused to cover them for patients with
canceled cancer or sickle-cell anemia
and even when patients weren't denied
coverage they had to jump through more
hoops than dolphins at SeaWorld now
there's no denying we've got an opioid
problem but to make it worse with broad
strokes based on fear and misinformation
for one the problem isn't prescription
opioids but street fentanyl the
addiction rate for prescriptions is low
the overdoses from street drugs are not
so broadly targeting the prescription
side only harms cancer patients as well
as other people with chronic and acute
pain meaning the lawful not the law less
as the media frames this as an epidemic
what you get is the same old one size
crushes all reaction that smacks every
fly with a hammer if you're a
conservative and disagree consider
firearms should you punish lawful gun
owners for the crimes of street gangs
armed with illegal weapons no that would
be a violation of your rights
so why suspend that logic here the
problem with opioids is that they work
and the worst thing you can do is let
the government transfer business to the
drug dealer who is more than happy to
oblige
so David the good news here is that the
CDC is actually kind of changing their
their their story and saying now you can
prescribe them for certain things
they're kind of loosening the reins
right so they overreacted to a problem
that look people weren't worried right
it also to the bad actors there were
some that we remember the the pushing
out - yeah tens of thousands of pills -
one little town and then sitting around
fake prescriptions all of that but yes
you said the government makes messes
things up right so I have an idea why
don't we have it take over all of our
healthcare there you go that's the thing
that I don't understand the whole
medicare-for-all piece but we'll find
out as he does his town hall with us on
Monday I also think that when you have
government overreaction to a problem and
you see that over and over again is
about to happen in the tech sector yes
right so government is always behind
yeah on innovations yeah technology and
then they're trying to make up for lost
times and they end up screwing things up
exactly you know Emily
during Prohibition there were deaths a
lot of deaths attributed to bathtub gin
because you couldn't buy it up in the
store yeah to make it the same cases is
happening here with opioids people end
up with street drugs and they die so
isn't it better to have prescriptions
where they could be you know modulated
and moderated yes to that also I want
viewers to understand that right now
we're seeing a rash of lawsuits and that
have come to a conclusion that have
included quite a large amount of
settlements that Big Pharma's are making
and for example I just want to use
Oklahoma for a second as a case study
for viewers to understand in this one
hundred and two hundred and seventy
million dollar settlement all of that
money is going its private money
obviously from these drug makers who did
not admit liability but they agreed to
settle it's going to state institutions
and that's all staying within the state
of Oklahoma and so who do you think
however is going to fund this after that
initial 270 million goes toward
establishing the National Center for
drug addiction and treatment and
providing those medicines the taxpayers
will assume that debt afterwards
obviously and as you guys I'm sure
remember after the big tobacco fiasco
and in the late 90s there was a huge or
there the debacle was what happened with
the money mismanagement after with those
millions of dollars of payments and
settlements played out so I just went
that everyone should keep track and note
what is occurring with these settlements
and what happens and who carries the
bill moving forward Joe there has been
some progress one in the sense that I
think the president Trump convinced
China to crack down on the Chinese
fentanyl and their drug dealers and I
think they're being I don't know if
they're being punished by death if
they're arrested but in China so you
know I and in sort of agreement with you
but I think we're we part company is I
think a lot of doctors I think the
pharmaceutical companies pushed opioids
legal opioids at a very high rate into
some communities especially poor
communities with tragic consequences and
when we hear about settlements even if
they don't admit liability I think
there's a reason for the settlement they
know that they could get a hit even
harder so for my money I think you know
what
we've had pain management before we had
opioids there are other ways to deal
with pain but I think if we pull back
and say oh you know what people should
have total access to opiates through the
doctor we don't understand the doctors
in fact we're part of the problem we
don't understand that the manufacturer
said no more than the doctors well I
think I think that we're like we could
talk about abortion on that front but
yes I agree with you but I do think that
when government sees that the people are
being hurt and we do have high rates of
death tied to this both the street and
before that they have been very very
inaccurate on the pure opioid overdose
is the rate of addiction from people who
use opioids is so small the two studies
that I've read the two major studies
showed it's like 1% tell me more about
this bathtub gin if you make something
illegal people will just flock to the
illegal and I'm sure I'm sure that's
never happened to you though Jesse no
never happened to me you know people say
about you you know you're on the Trump
train you know you choo-choo driving the
trip
not on this man you're fighting against
the Trump war on opioids I think I am
yeah absolutely yes so fare imbalance I
think he's being cynical I also think
he's being inaccurate yes I think
thought about the Train but about issue
what is going on here fact-check me